[موسيقى]
يتعلق بالسلاح او بالدول اعضاء الناتو
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالعتاد فان الجنرالات
يرغبون بصفه عامه برؤيه قتال يرغبون في
استخدام التجهيزات التي جرى انفاق الكثير
عليها من اجل نقلها الى اوكرانيا الولايات
المتحده ام فقط ملا يقل عن 900 مليار
دولار في موازنه دفاعيه سنويه هذا اكثر من
عشره اضعاف اجمالي مساهمت به كل الدول
الاعضاء الاخرى في الناتو مجتمعه هذا مبلغ
ضخم وخيالي لدى اوكرانيا هذا الكم من
الصواريخ والدبابات والتجهيزات وكل
المساهمين يرغبون برؤيتها وهي بصدد
الاستخدام هم يرغبون بان يثبتوا لدافع
الضرائب بان التمويل هذه التجهيزات كان
مبررا وكان استثمارا من اجل الامن القومي
ايضا هناك منافسه تجاريه امريكا مصدر كبير
للسلاح وكذلك روسيا فنحن بصدد حرب
بالوكاله وكبار مسلحيها سلاح او مصنعيه
يرغبون بهذا القتال بين افضل ما انتجت
التكنولوجيا العسكريه الغربيه
ومنافستها الروسيه
[موسيقى]
فكلما تعلق الامر بتحليل اداء القوات
الاوكرانيه فانه يتعين تعليق العمل
بالمنطق المتعارف عليه فمن توقع في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير العام الماضي عندما
اقتحمت القوات الروسيه العاصمه
ان يتم طردها وبسرعه من قبل القوه
الاوكرانيه ثم اثر ذلك تحقيق مكاسب عبر
ارجاء بلادهم ما قالته وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه وجنرال لا تهم منطقي من حيث
الحاجه الى امتلاك الخبرات لكن الجنود
الاوكرانيين يبداون التدريب وهم لهم معرفه
به بنوع السلاح وكيفيه استخدامه يعرفون
كيف يستخدمون دبابه او صاروخا وذلك ما
يجعل من مده التعلم اكثر ايضا هناك الطاقه
التي يمنحها دافع الرغبه في التعلم ولذلك
كانت تلقي المعلومات اسهل الظروف حكمت على
الاوكرانيين بسرعه الاستيعاب مثلما كان
الامر يت باي تلميذ مجتهدا في المدرسه
[موسيقى]